all right this morning we are marking 75
years since the liberation
of the auschwitz concentration camp in
poland auschwitz was the largest
nazi death camp today around 200
survivors
are expected there they're honored
guests at a place where they were once
sent
to die earlier several of them laid
wreaths in honor of those who didn't
make it out
mark phillips is at auschwitz speaking
with survivors
who have an urgent message to share
auschwitz is not only the largest of the
death camps where more than a million
people
90 of them jews were murdered by the
nazis
it's also become a center of holocaust
remembrance
and today it poses a question are we
forgetting the lessons of this place
the soviet red army liberated auschwitz
75 years ago today
and took the pictures that forever
etched its horrors in our minds
those images have been colorized in a
new history channel documentary
some though don't need enhanced pictures
to bring back those vivid terrible
memories
a few remaining survivors have returned
here
in their 90s now they've come for a
reason
and with the message and it should never
happen again
david marks is 91 now he was 16 when he
was crammed into a cattle car with
thousands of others and brought here
from hungary
this is not only his first time back
it's his first time
talking about it i didn't talk about it
with my children i didn't want they
should know what i went through
you wouldn't speak to them about it i
didn't speak to them at all
he didn't tell them of the watchtowers
and the wire
and the filth and the starvation and he
didn't tell them what happened
during the horror of the selection
process when
camp officers decided who might live for
a while
and who would die so you were selected
for work
and your father and your brother were
sent confidently to the
to the gas chamber that same day 35
members of my family
were burned were cremated the same day
that friday david mark somehow survived
he moved to the u.s in the 50s widowed
27 years ago
he is now engaged to marry kathy this
summer
it was she who convinced him to return
to auschwitz
for closures he says world jewish
congress president
ronald louder says there's another
reason the survivors need to tell their
stories now
are you concerned at the rise of
anti-semitic incidents particularly over
the last few years
i'm very concerned about it because
when i look at what happened and i speak
to survivors
and they tell me how it started off very
small it got bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger
is that what you're seeing i'm seeing
that same thing
the survivors numbers are dwindling few
think they'll ever be back to this place
all that will be left is the wire and
the watchtowers
and the ovens and their stories
mark phillips thank you thank you very
much mean it shows the capacity for
for recovery that human beings have yep
and so important for the stories to be
told i love the
the thinking that may we never forget
and that's why it's so important that we
keep telling it it's so amazing that he
that that man's been carrying that story
with him since he was 16
and he's now 91 and finally talking
about it
now because people are forgetting yeah